findest du im leben kommen du bist nicht
witzig ein bisschen empire grüne
manchmal dumme viel hallo und willkommen
zu minecraft leben zusammen mit der
waffe zum weinen wo bist du
wir haben gerade einfach diese mega
kranke hundebett ross auf stoffels kanal
aufgenommen die wahrscheinlich gestern
oder so gekommen ist und seitdem sind
wir einfach beide richtig toll die
zurück in folge und überleben quatschen
folgen gesehen
deswegen haben habe ich bei twitter
einfach mal gefragt was er von dem wagen
von leben und dass da einfach dass ihre
fragen stellen könnt oder euro sein
da hat der stoffel einvernehmen bei
twitter auch von dem bei wollen wir
meine inneneinrichtung ein wenig machen
und damit produkte produktiv sein
deswegen will ich sagen wir begeben uns
schon mal bei mir hier in die
inneneinrichtung bei facebook ja fang
deine fragen schreibt schlecht fragt
wann bekommt ihr bei den ersten
minecraft leben baby nachwuchs geht wie
jedes facebook facebook babys der babys
erwarten wenn man euch auf den straßen
sieht davon aufzuhören und umarmen zu
rennen kritisch zu laufen gerne mal zu
rennen und dann bin ich wieder so eine
küche wieder ein abstecher auf die auch
weg also ich hab jetzt nicht zuviel
gegen nur ich finds halt immer komisch
wenn dann leute so mega anfang
hysterisch zu werden
da denke ich mir dann immer nur so acom
mädels jungs wir sind halt auch normal
irgendwie so nämlich eigentlich dass man
babys machen jetzt das nächste leben
auch wenn es mal eine stunde fangen
gespielt
weiter du bist der einzige der sein haus
hier noch nicht fertig hat das ist auch
gar nicht mein haus mein haus werde ich
immer mit hut meinte richter nicht
gesehen
willkommen also kommen du kannst dich
doch hätte ich doch ein bisschen aus mit
inneneinrichtung oder eine wiese in eine
richtung
jetzt muss das doch ganz anders machen
dass mir gesagt du hast sie inspirieren
lassen von diesem wagen komplett oder
voll freude geile hauptschule dann
daraus gemacht natürlich auch aber ich
möchte nicht alles so machen wie in
diesem video mal musste sich aber du
kannst 57 ja ähnlich sein
hier setzt man brot wollt ihr euch das
auf hero 2 das am ende des jahres
startet was einfach überstimmt und der
höheren macht überhaupt keinen sinn hat
noch niemand irgendwie gesagt von daher
von einer hatte noch nie irgendjemanden
was zu illegales beiden im starttermin
oder irgendwie dass das war dagegen
ich habe nur gesagt einmal dass ich
finde dass heroes heroes' somit das
projekt war und dass ich mir so was gern
mal wieder wünschen würde und da auf
jeden fall bock drauf hätte aber wie
kann man denn sagen einfach so als user
ja hero 2 was macht ihr da der selbst
ist all die leute die wollen jetzt eine
antwort von der daraus quetschen
du hast du sagst wie am ende des jahres
viel druck dass über bestimmte freunde
links gestern leben kommen
das ist gotteshaus hier vorne
das sind ja immer noch sehr
bemerkenswert das ist einfach so nicht
mittelalterlich aber ich find's cool das
haus wie soll im sommer ruft und es
matrone weg ist das zweite mal dieser
folge dass ich komisch in die fans gebe
bei der entwicklung wurden hier wohnt
pixel wohl
interessiert man guckt und hier ich muss
weg ich muss weg zum zweck der eiermann
cook tcg aber an ihr lassen sich perfekt
mit alternden in den elite tritt der fdp
lösen und später lernt man lieber sonst
recht werde die ein schwarzmarkt gründen
fragt moritz gemeinschaft leben
handwerks gilt es ja eigentlich dafür
bekannt dass sie sehr legal legitime
geschäfte vollführt die bisher zweite
aufgekommen sind
aber das ist ja in europa die auch immer
noch nicht steht das hauptquartier
freunde wir werden demnächst wenn
beistand von leben anfängt habe ich
eigentlich schon wieder fallen sinnlose
scheiße nebel werden einfach demnächst
vielleicht irgendwann mal das gebäude
dann fertig gewesen zu sein ein bisschen
überlegen was dieser handwerks bilder
genau darstellen soll und zwei das wort
aber das wird schon noch irgendwie es
hat schon wieder jemand verfolgt oder
was gerade einfach das gefühl da war
schon wieder jemand hinter mir gerade
ich bin so total paranoid in den regen
stehen die schilder ziemlich leichte
drohung wenn nicht mal etwas put gehen
kann
ich kriege dich es kann wirklich nichts
kaputt gemacht nichts habe vor allem die
lose acht er meinte das einfach weil dnt
macht er keine
wieso liegt denn jetzt ein zombie gehirn
vor meiner tür der jedermann sichtbar
oder wieso also hier alle sind negativ
aus friedens bruch darf sie aber töten
also die auf dem grundstück sind ist
aber hier das rad gelaufen
ich fasse ich verstehe doch da war doch
noch irgendwie war der durchführung
dieser eiermann
so weiß ich weil die blöden stelle jetzt
mal ab sollen jedoch sage und schreibe
ich jetzt erstmal schild in mir egal was
ihr denkt hat sich das gerät überhaupt
nicht nur denkt hengst nein das ist ein
richtiger moneyball rjm
es ist echt man müsse etwas produktives
wirtschaft das einzige was bisher
gemacht habe ist die kakaobohnen
abgeerntet andrea zehn minuten so dass
man hier immer zu wenn er wenn er
reinkommt dann wissen dass sie direkt
auf die schnauze
der typ laser mir umgehen ich den nahm
ich den namen des gewinners
aber da ist jemand empfang mehr ab oh oh
oh
vollkommen legal gewesen das vr legal
gewesen ja auf dem grundstück aber es
ist mein grundstück und du hast ihn
getötet wie aber ich habe mich mit
verteidigt das wollte ich aber gar nicht
das ist ein regelbruch staffel ich
entschuldige mich weil wir einfach
richtig chaotisch ist wieder wer hat die
relativ schnell da nicht gelesen und man
aber freunde ich bin jetzt ehrlich mit
euch ich weiß echt nicht in
einrichtungen
hallo tourist history in der einrichtung
kann ich einfach nicht und deswegen
drücke ich mich davor mal so ein
bisschen und auch man und du warst in
klein auf steinau tine wittler mustern
oder eingesperrt
ich bin dort leben wieder drauf
ohne spaß machen
ich könnte mich kann nicht einen
touristenbus sagen fragen
freunde wir sind echt einfach ich
entschuldige mich diese formel 1 zeit
verschwendet habe einfach so wie sie
dumm gelaufen wenn würde dass der pastor
seine frage jetzt zu kommen wie findest
du die bisherige entwicklung des
projekts also jetzt nicht mit gut
schlecht sondern wie finde was sollte
man machen
ich muss unbedingt meine audio
einstellungen anpassen woran die wieder
die born nicht wieder die haben
aufgehört aber gerade weil sie aufgehört
haben
richtig dass jetzt mehr auf meine stimme
und damit meine stimme viel lauter und
viel unwillkürlich natürlicher
kleiderständer du bist doch voll weit
gekommen ist schön kleiderständer in
einer wohnung
ich möchte noch was für uns hier leider
noch nicht klar als kleiner oder
bisherige entwicklung des projektes
finde ich ganz fest aus
mit lass ich finde ich ganz cool das ist
so verschiedene sache gibt es gibt leute
die grauen mega viel off screen und
haben halt auch geiler geiler häuser
dann hingekriegt oder wo es gibt leute
die konzentrierten auftritt player etc
und dann gibt's halt solche leute die
mich die nichts haben
ich bin echt zufrieden mit der du musst
mal stream für dein ego können vier
stunden stream eine klassische mal alles
raus hier
ja ja ja ja wird irgendwann mal wird das
noch mal kommen
ihr seid echt mal so wenn ich irgendwann
mal zeit finde dann nutzen sie um videos
aufzunehmen und wenn ich dann noch
stream würdest passt derzeit einfach
rein
aber freunde tapeziert noch irgendwie
hin man daher noch eine schnelle frage
dann eine freude ich bin nicht nur so
ich großes entschuldigung an alle eine
riesige
da war ich jetzt geküsst natürlich ist
schalke in frankfurt gekürt
jetzt könnt ihr mann am bahnhof bauen
ist die letzten tage erstmal erstmal
handwerks bilde dann kümmern wir uns um
andere woche einen fucking bahnhof und
ich kriege meine inneneinrichtungen und
von mir wird im bahnhof verlangt auch
man freunde das ist ein echter airways
kämpft alle oder schwarze freunde ich
muss mich wirklich entschuldigen ich hab
paar stunden geschlafen und nichts mit
sturm war für diesem etwas runder bei
seinem kanal aufgenommen ich bin so tot
jetzt danach ich hab so gelacht man mir
tut es leid ich verändere die folge
bitte leid dass wir einfach nicht und
doch das kommt bei 5.000 bitte leidet es
nicht wissen geht einfach
schaut euch irgendwas besten modus war
es egal welches jetzt